Paul starts off this hour in Orlando
Florida hey Paul how are you well I'm
hanging in there mr. Ramsey Oh Oh what's
going on
well I'm 78 years old
my wife is 76
14 months ago I went through a quadruple
heart bypass surgery and a valve
replacement Wow my wife is in the
hospital right now she's had a major
stroke I'm sorry
we are $28,000 in debt to finance
companies and we are right at this
particular point in time our bills are
up to date but we're having to go to a
payday loan to get money to take care of
them every month and it you know we got
rash but we don't have the beans to go
in them and we've reached the point that
we're ready to file bankruptcy and I've
listened to you for a long time what
what's your suggestion okay um do you
own home no sir
we live it up do you own a car no sir we
have a 30 year old RV that we live in we
owe about $3,000 on it we have a 21 year
old automobile that was paid for but we
had to spend over $1,100 to get some
repairs done on it
does it and lean against the title on it
no sir it does not
okay and what is your income sir between
the two of us it's two thousand one
hundred and four dollars a month okay
and how much is your RV payment uh my RV
payment is $300 a month where do you
park it we live in a park out here in
Orlando and the gentleman owns the park
the rent is usually about five 25 35 a
month we're into it for 425 a month
including
electricity water sewer the whole bet
okay
so the payment on the RV and the payment
to the park doesn't go away if you want
a place to live now in any scenario no
so then there are less time that the
rest of the debt is what's called
unsecured debt it does not have a lien
on anything okay no and don't ever walk
into another payday loan place ever
now here's what I would walk you through
I don't think I would file bankruptcy on
only twenty eight thousand dollars in
debt even though you have this bearing
down on you and this driving you crazy
but here's the scenario okay if any of
those people sue you there's not
anything they can get your what we in
the business called judgment proof well
one of the finance companies two of them
are signature loans that's all it
doesn't matter okay the third one the
people told us is well we've got to have
some collateral I said I don't have it
well make up something and put it down
as long as it comes to $5,000 what did
you put down I put down a couple
television sets computers fishing
equipment stuff like that and we didn't
have it I told her eyes we don't hide
that stuff okay well if you know it's
here on paper that's all it matters okay
so they encourage you to commit fraud
and you did yes sir so that that's going
to be a problem for them and for you if
they want to get nasty but bottom line
is is they can't repo stuff that's not
there yeah okay so none of these people
can get paid unless you choose to pay
them because if they sue you they can't
get anything there's nothing to get yeah
okay
that's my point and that puts you in a
good position in terms of working with
them long term so given that situation
here's what I would do if I were in your
shoes the first thing you buy out of
your $2,100 is food
the second thing you buy is you pay the
RV payment and you pay the lot payment
yeah now we have a place to live we have
water to drink and we have electricity
and we have food yeah okay we haven't
used up $2,100 yet but you need to
prioritize your mind in your mind what's
most important food is first yeah the
second most important thing is shelter
and that's cost you seven hundred
twenty-five dollars between those two
payments right and so you know if you
spend $500 a month or $400 a month on
food you've still got almost a thousand
dollars to begin to work on some other
stuff with as you want to and can but
there's not anything they can get
because the money coming to you is
Social Security and it's they can't put
a garnishment on it well I pay my
mother's phone bill every month and
that's only forty six dollars I mean mom
is 96 years old you can do that I mean
you're gonna choose to pay that bill but
then you what I would do from there then
is I would look at these other debts the
other 28,000 and pick out one and begin
to work on it and just let the other sit
they're going to scream and flop in the
floor and foam at the mouth but so what
if you file bankruptcy they're gonna do
the same thing and you're going to spend
a thousand or fifteen hundred bucks to
file a bankruptcy that you really only
need to file because they can't get
anything well our doctor his brother is
an attorney and he's representing as
free gratis on the bankruptcy and yeah
that's what he suggested we do if he
will file the bankruptcy for free then
if you want to do it that's fine you've
cleared it all up but then from this
point forward
you've got 2,100 - 725 - food and you
don't you'll never do anything else
except with cash the rest of your life
yeah you because you're done I mean you
cannot go back in these places you can't
think about it I mean you just you can't
go to a payday loan I don't care how
scared or how how broke you feel or how
desperate you feel to repair your old
car you just can't repair it until you
have the money yeah right
but a bankruptcy will clean this up and
if you'll do it for free you're clearing
off twenty eight thousand dollars worth
of stuff and you are legitimately broke
there's no question about that well the
only thing I have to pays the filing fee
which I think he serves one hundred and
forty dollars yeah that sounds right
that sounds right okay and if he'll take
good care of you and walk you through it
it's really not I mean it's a difficult
thing to go through and with your wife
being ill and you facing all of this
it's an emotional thing to go through
and I never recommend it you've listened
to me for years but if you want to go
through that I'm not mad at you
yeah you know you're in this situation
because these people are being nasty I
mean you're getting phone calls that are
making person's hair curdle right now
well one of them was very very nice
because I explained to them what and one
of those what about the other ones
they're pretty upset with yeah well
they're just that's the technique they
use and their nastiness just boxed you
into a corner while your wife's in the
hospital with a stroke and you're 78
years old so I shouldn't have done that
it wasn't wise on their part I mean if
you go through this I'll help you any
way I can if you don't go through it
what I just outlined to work to if you
got a guy filing it for free you know
it's a viable option in this situation
so good luck with your brother sorry
you're facing this this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you